i think listen
i i'm listen the other day like about a
week ago i live in i live in phoenix
out on the morning news two pilots were
flying in from new mexico into phoenix
they were just taking a plane
and and you hear they played the the the
because they were communicating with the
faa tower and he was like listen
i really hate to say this but something
just flew right over the top of us oh
yeah i saw that i heard that
yeah and he was like i really hate to
say it but it was a silver cylindrical
[ __ ] disc
he's like something just and dude these
people that's 30 000 feet drones don't
fly at 30
000 feet yeah they can't they just don't
operate they also said there was no
sound
yeah yeah like they didn't mention what
kind of propulsion
yeah it was like if it was a pro like a
a jet
a jet yeah you would hear it yeah yeah
ufos don't use
jets it's coming man it's coming dude
like listen these the alien whoever's
observing our society from you know
distance from a distance because it's it
that's
a thing i'm i'm almost positive not that
i have proof
um listen they're gonna be like listen
these little [ __ ]
hairless monkeys are really [ __ ]
getting out of hand over here we gotta
[ __ ] intervene
they're [ __ ] up they they split the
atom you know what i mean they're
[ __ ]
making nuclear explosions we gotta get
down there and intervene like
something's gonna happen
you know i just watched this crazy
[ __ ] documentary where they were
breaking it down they were saying like
they found a
neanderthal baby in a cave perfectly
preserved
and they [ __ ] they took they
sequenced the dna
using like i don't know if you're
familiar with crispr yeah
so they sequenced the dna and they were
like there's no way that humans
evolved from neanderthals there's no way
there's no way
because in the short amount of time that
it took for for us from neanderthal to
us
it's just a blink of an eye and it took
you know if you know you know about lucy
right
yes the first [ __ ] primate so you
know when they sequenced the
the or they they couldn't because she
was a fossil but so they're saying like
the leap from lucy to neanderthal was
like a million years
and they say that our dna is so vastly
[ __ ] different from the neanderthals
that it would have taken
just the amount of time it does
something doesn't make sense
so then they're they're they're they're
hinting at [ __ ] you know
intervention and advanced advanced we
can do evolution
we can do it with our technology now
who's to say that a a different
civilization from that can get here from
a different solar solar system
hasn't already accomplished [ __ ]
genetics some kind of genetic
engineering it's just
if you have the technology to get here
from a different [ __ ] solar system
right you've got the genetics figured
out
you got that part you got you got that
figured out so it's not really
i know it's insane to think about that
but it's not really that far-fetched
to imagine something like that happening
given what we know
about is that what you believe the human
i have to see more evidence yeah you
know what i mean i they need to dig up
10 more [ __ ]
uh neanderthal babies and sequence the
[ __ ] dna you know what i mean for me
it's just you know i i have to see more
evidence i'm not going to take that one
study and be like oh i'm sold
yeah you know but it's just like that's
like a it's like a holy grail type
question though right
like the missing there's like there's
like three questions like are we alone
where do we go after we die yeah and and
how did we where did we come from
why are we here those are you know those
are some of the things that keep me up
at night believe it or not
you know what i mean like i i probably
spend way more time than i should
thinking about those types of things but
it's fun
yeah i mean like it's fun like i enjoy
it you know i get lost for hours
sometimes just like [ __ ]
contemplating like all of those things
you know
it's fun yeah the idea of
of some other beings coming down and
like altering
monkey dna or chimpanzee sci-fi to
accelerate
the evolution and create us these
hairless
a science experiment big headed
blimp-headed beings
yeah i mean that's and then cause those
neanderthals i mean they have
huge giant bodies and tiny heads and
then we are like
their forehead stuck out way bigger
their jaws were a lot bigger their
brains were you know their whole
physiology was just different than ours
i mean they're they're
homo you know they're of the species but
they're not
you know we're just so much different
from them so much so they're trying to
figure out what happened
what could happen that could change us
in just such a short amount of time
jesus well yeah that's a whole other
conversation
um because you know you know evolution
is a product of adaptation
yeah you know what i mean so you're in
your environment the environment
plays almost a certain role in the
direction of a species that's going to
go as far as their physical attributes
because right
you know certain you know uh things in
nature activate
certain [ __ ] you know things in our
genome that over a certain amount of
times
allows us to uh exuberate or
i don't know if that's the word i want
to use but um
display uh different characteristics you
know what i mean like
white people are white because we grew
up or we evolved in
in kind of colder climates where there
wasn't so much sun so our skins didn't
you know our skin tone didn't develop
more melanin in it to protect it from
the sun that's why you know black people
are black because they come from africa
where it's constant sun so the melon
it's just the environment changes us
physically
you know what i mean so there's such a
short amount of time that they just
don't understand how we got from [ __ ]
that to where we are now
yeah so quickly so i mean yeah so it's
like something had to have happened and
there's
nothing even remotely like us there's
nothing that wears [ __ ]
sneakers that can tattoo their bodies
like
like designs on their own skin and sell
being self-aware to the point so that we
are
they're closed there's no other stuff
that can even contemplate the things
that we can contemplate that can think
about well how where'd i come from
because that that's a big question and
that question says a lot about
the human psyche and just where we are
in our state of evolution
yeah you know but evolution's done we
killed that with the industrial
revolution and everything else because
we control our environment now so that's
what i was saying about technology
about ai the next step of human
evolution is going to be electronic
if we're going to be [ __ ] inside we
already are cyborgs you know what i mean
this these things are never within our
arms we reach away from you
everybody in this room you know what i
mean i sleep with it under my [ __ ]
pillow it's never
farther than arm's length away so the
problem with the technology the reason
it's being innovated like it is
is just to make money profit for the
only reason
that's the only thing the only reason we
keep making new iphones every year or
keep developing new apps new whatever
yeah is so they can just sell more
advertising i agree with you 100
but i think that's the beginning because
now it's
it's the amount of technology and the
things that are readily available to the
small sect of people that actually do
want to change humanity
is those tools are now readily available
so now we're going to start seeing you
know giant leaps and bounds and like
you know the medical the medical
industry with like health care
and you know the vaccines that we're
going to all the rolling out and the new
medications and all the [ __ ] that's
coming down the pipeline
uh i believe is going to be a product of
that and i was trying to explain to
my girlfriend i think a couple weeks ago
and i was like listen
when you and i get older it's not going
to be people taking care of us
it's going to be robots it's going to be
robots taking care of the elderly
because they're already doing it in
japan
where they got the [ __ ] robot that
can scoop [ __ ] the old people out of
their bed and [ __ ] take them to the
bathroom and [ __ ]
they're already doing it in japan and
china you know what i mean
so like i haven't even seen that oh yeah
dude check that out it's on uh you you
heard the
the wii volver w-e-e-v-o-l-v-e-r
they're like a a science and tech um
channel
and dude yeah they got all kinds of
crazy [ __ ] but yeah so it's like like
when we're elderly it's gonna be robots
taking care of us
which i prefer you know what i mean i
don't want some little 21 year old
[ __ ] girl with blue hair [ __ ] on
her telephone i'm over here [ __ ] and
pissing like i'm [ __ ] choking on my
catheter
and she's on [ __ ] instagram you know
what i mean i don't need that talking
i don't need that i need a cold
calculated [ __ ]
robot that's gonna [ __ ] do the do the
proper things you know what i mean to
make sure that i'm
staying alive you know so like i said
man futures the future is going to be
if we if we [ __ ] if we make it you
know what i mean because we might not
[ __ ] make it that far
we might just shoot the whole [ __ ]
thing
you